i've always been that super strong
person like i always had the answers and
i could always fix everything and i've
always been in charge and
i could i could
i could deal with anything you bring it
to me and i got you you know what i'm
saying i can hold it down and we'll make
it happen and we're going to fix it
we'll take care of it it'll be okay and
i will always say it will be okay we
will make it
we got this
i don't got this anymore
i really don't
i'm really tired
all right brianna
yes brianna where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
i was born in wheeling
um
when i was five moved to seattle area
and when i was 13 moved back to
charleston
and by the time i was 14 i was awarded
the state
and
stayed in custody of state until i was
18.
and then
um
once i was 18
i had my first baby when i was 19
and then just
life from there
what was your childhood like
um
[Applause]
honestly like i don't really remember a
whole lot from my childhood um
i know that
i lived in a
a um
a
a lesbian
household my mom is lesbian
um
i
really really honestly i don't remember
like hardly anything i know when i was
11.
i was living in everett washington with
my mom and her girlfriend and her
girlfriend's daughter
and i didn't like her girlfriend and my
mom didn't really pay a lot of attention
to me i remember being raped when i was
11.
i would run away from home all the time
you're right by who uh maintenance
worker that came into the apartment one
day when i decided not to go to school i
would always skip school i didn't fit in
anywhere i was always the outcast i was
kind of fat i was a fat kid
and um so you know i didn't get the home
life wasn't good i would skip school all
the time running right run away i was
really incorrigible
i just never belonged
anywhere so what kind of kid were you in
high school um
i really i didn't where i was
a ward of the state in custody of the
state you never went to high school not
really
as soon as i tried to roll enroll into
capitol high school here in charleston
um
they said that my credits were so messed
up from being cut in custody
that i went to court and
the judge went ahead and ordered for me
to take my ged
early and i did and i got my ged
and i'm educated i say
like i graduated i went to school from
there
i graduated from medical assisting top
of my class in phlebotomy
i used to work with the mentally
impaired and the handicapped through the
arc of three rivers here which was
hands down the best job i've ever had in
my life
because those people are amazing
and
you know they completed me like that
i mean it fulfilled me
it was awesome that's great so
and i mean and i always
wanted to take care of everybody when i
was 13 i told my mom i was going to save
the world she said no you're not i said
yeah i am
so
you know
i get so angry now i really sometimes
really would like to just set the whole
world on fire and sit back and watch it
burn but
but at the end of the day i still don't
want to do that either i'd really rather
just save the world somehow i know i
can't save the world
i wonder if i can even save myself at
this point i'm trying
but
you have how many kids i have three kids
i have two girls and a boy
um i believe my daughter my youngest
daughter
um she is
i believe she's 20.
i'm not real close with her
but i do
see her occasionally and trying to man
that relationship that was really badly
destroyed between both of our faults
uh years ago
and she beat me for a year nobody
believed me
anyhow uh
i have a
25 year old son
who is my baby boy and he is absolutely
amazing and we're very close
um
and then i have a 26 year old daughter
and she's so beautiful too my kids are
beautiful
and she's amazing as well
and she's really lost as well too though
can and
she has two kids of her own that she
doesn't even have my two grandkids so
which are
absolutely amazing too my grandson i've
only seen once
my granddaughter stays with my mom
who
really honest god i believe hates me
honestly i don't think she ever wanted
me i really believe i'm a product of
rape
um
anyhow
with that being said though she takes
care of my granddaughter
and she doesn't know how to take care of
her because my granddaughter's autistic
and i tell my mom all the time i can
help her
she says that
i can't help her
she won't let me just take some time to
tell her what to do my granddaughter was
supposed to be born on my birthday
and she was born four days before that
and
she hasn't talked yet she's four her
name is serenity she's
beautiful
she's amazing but she's been talking to
me
for a long time and i can hear every
word she says and i just wish i could
get her out of there and take care of
her myself
i've been trying to do that because my
mom can't handle it but i can't seem to
get there
so i found you
walking the street early this morning in
the rain yeah
where'd you sleep last night
i slept um
on the other side
of man of meals on the backside of me
and meals across the road there
at a church
with a friend of mine
you're outside yep outside
um on the front steps of the church
how long have you been on the streets
i believe it's been like 10 months now
um probably not the first time depending
on how you want to look at my life you
know what i'm saying because you know as
a teenager i was too
it was different though when i was a
teenager i can handle it a lot better
45 years old and
worn down body and bad health and
really tired
you know takes toll on you after a while
so
but roughly 10 months
and i will say that it's been rather
humbling and i wouldn't change it for
the world
i don't understand a lot of things
i don't i feel like i'm being targeted
to
like
but i'm grateful i mean i've met a lot
of amazing people in my life and i
wouldn't change this experience for the
world
but i would like to move past it though
i'm ready to move past it because
regardless i'm going to be passed it
sooner rather than later
with being sick and whatnot but
you know
are drugs a part of your life they are a
part of my life they don't have to be
out required for them to be i'm not
strung out or addicted and so to speak
in such a way
i do drugs because i like to do them
because i enjoy doing them if i
had to make a choice tomorrow and get up
and walk away from them could i do that
yeah
i'm really good at selling them
which i mean like i was explaining at
one point just
that you know
at least
i'm not proud of the things that i've
had to do my whole life but
at least i held it down and i took care
of my people i was good at it and
you know pissed a lot of people off
because i had good business prospects
make good business deals and could offer
better deals and
better stuff
i guess so
but you're still a survivor
i've been a survivor right now
though like i'm just really tired
i am tired of surviving
i just want to be okay
does it get uh
does it make you depressed or angry or
anxious
how does it affect you emotionally
emotionally all of this um
i think i find myself
being angry
i'm really angry about a lot of things
and anger comes from
[Music]
from caring
and being hurt and let down and left
behind
and not understanding being confused
trying to make sense of things that
i probably won't ever
be able to make sense of
being lonely i'm so lonely
and i mean i'm okay with being alone
but after a while you know you sit
and the voices in your head they get to
you
and you try to drown them out
and sometimes they get so loud and
sometimes it scares you though because
like their ideas like they sound
fantastic because you know
but they're not always so good to try to
fight those off sometimes they win
though
mine i just uh i don't want to let them
win because that means i will give up
and i will give in and i will go jump
off that bridge
and i like my friend said the other day
he said sure bray you can fly till you
hit the bottom
you know
and uh
i think i've already hit bottom a few
times and i haven't jumped yet
is this pretty much your lowest point in
your life
i think so
you know
i i really do
because like i've always been that super
strong person like i always had the
answers and i could always fix
everything and i've always been in
charge and
i could i could
i could deal with anything you bring it
to me and i got you you know i'm saying
i can hold it down and we'll make it
happen and we're gonna fix it we'll take
care of it it'll be okay and i will
always say it we'll be okay we will make
it
we got this
i don't got this anymore
i really don't
i am really tired
and i just want to sit down and breathe
and i feel like i'm struggling here to
breathe i feel like i'm suffocating here
and knowing that i am gonna die that i'm
sick
with bone cancer and
a heart condition that i didn't know
that i had till recently after losing
another toe
after everything sounds severely anemic
and and
all these surgeries i've had in my body
and my body aches so bad
i just i mean i just want to go so badly
to the beach somewhere warm to the beach
down south i've never been to the keys i
used to live in saint pete
but i've never been down to the keys
bahamas mexico anything like that i just
want to sit in the sand every day
maybe smoke a little bit of weed
try to take the edge off
watch the sunset
and every time i've ever been in the
beach i felt like i could breathe you
know like i don't know what it
is it's beautiful
and this place i look around this place
and i mean like
we we worry about like all this copic
and and this at the other
and i put out my big conspiracy theory
like with the movie the walking dead
show the walking dead but i walk around
every day and i see nothing but dead
people around me already because
everybody is so dying inside
because i am too slowly and it's that's
the bad part though that it's so slow
it is so slow that that's why it grabs a
hold of people so badly because i mean
it just slowly just drags everybody
i mean do you think being in west
virginia is a big part of your problem
me right now yeah
because there's really a side outside of
my granddaughter
maybe my grandson who's i only got to
see him once
and my son
and maybe that man that i so guess
really fell in love with
which i never thought i would ever get i
swear to god you fell in love recently
yeah
and i don't even really know him
but it felt like that
i've known him forever
and i want him so bad
but i'm grateful
because i never thought that i would
love or be loved again
or to feel safe in anybody's arms ever
again my ex
my ex told me he said brie
he said no but he wants you not even me
proved him wrong
so you found that recently yeah but
you're
that you're living on the street
by yourself tonight
yeah
thank you
why was he not with you
well because when i first met him three
months ago
um
i
asked him to come with me and ask him to
leave the shelter and we spent a weekend
together
and uh
you know that was probably kind of
selfish actually you know what i'm
saying
but he wanted to do it too he had a
choice he made it he left with me we had
a good time
when we parted
i told him i would go to the hospital
with him because he was
not all right you know what i'm saying
and that would go figure out whatever
for him to make sure he was going to be
okay because i'm not that home wrecking
kind of person i want to make sure he
wasn't married or had a family and got
lost along the way
and i was willing to accept that if he
had and i would have still been there if
he wanted me to be there part of his
life as a friend however
i never thought i would see him again
i've been looking for him for two months
and i found him
and
i want him
and yesterday
kbc
said that we could go to sojourners to
the shelter together
they held a bed for us
because i already have a weakened immune
system from being sick with everything
else going on with my house i couldn't
even get into a shelter all winter
okay
it didn't matter what i did
i didn't have anywhere to go
and
they said go get your covetous because
you have to pass a rapid test to get
into the shelters
he said go get your coma test go do ac
abcd
we went we did all that and i don't like
the shelters or whatever and this hat
and the other
we did it all i passed that cove to test
but i don't know how that happened and i
passed that cover test this time and we
did it all and when we got to the
shelter yesterday they said no they
wouldn't take us
that we couldn't stay
because
they didn't consider him homeless
because
he was at the shelter
at the men's shelter
and
we were going to get married yesterday
they were gonna help us get married
don't mean like
and they wouldn't take us i mean i did
everything the right way we did what we
were supposed to do and then we were
still denied like that was the last
denial that i needed right there
that's what's making me give up on this
world
i mean i try to stay true i stick to my
word if i give you my word
my word is good
if i come at you sideways you know you
probably deserved it you probably earned
that
and half the time i don't even act on
that crap because
it's not even worth it
i needed this yesterday
i don't want much
i feel like i've had it all
i've lost it all
i really don't want much it wouldn't
take much to
for me to be happy that man makes me
happy brings life back into me
and when he walked away from me
love is difficult yeah boy
and there's a lot of things that are
difficult that is a huge one
for a lot of people
and i mean like i had said i mean i've
always been able to fix everything i've
always been really strong i've always
had the answers up
i've got nothing right now
i don't know what to do or where to go
who i could turn to
and i'm
so scared even more so right now because
i don't even know if i can count on me
right now because me is so lost right
now
i remember my son calling on
thanksgiving
and he said mom
he said i am so lost he said
i am so lost and i don't know what to do
and i know that feeling right now like i
don't think that i have ever felt this
lost in my life
like i feel like
i don't belong anywhere
and i know that my time is short already
and i don't really
want to die
but i'm so tired of living like this
are you kids
on the street too
my son was
my youngest daughter she's doing well
for herself my oldest daughter
and she's strung out and um
her boyfriend makes it
possible for her to stay strong you know
because he just gives her just enough to
keep her high during the day but not
enough to
you know whatever and he cheats on her
he's pretty mean to her too and
she knows it but she doesn't know what
to do either and
we don't really talk anymore and
my son is trying
and he was clean for a while and he went
to sober living and he was at the pack
house and he was doing the damn thing
and doing good and he's getting high
again but
he's looking for another job and he is
trying to hold it down so
i know that
if he could see me today right now
he would be so upset
my son i love my son it's always been me
and him and at the end of the day every
day all through our life my life with my
family and my kids
and i mean
my son was molested when he was one
or right before you turn one
um he ended up in a full body cast
he suffered a spiral right to the femur
bone
and
i took that to the grand jury five times
and that man managed to walk because
they said there wasn't enough evidence
he supposedly has 11 boy foster children
in his home right now
and the lady that
runs the office down at kbc
her husband is best friends with him
which makes me wonder if that's why
maybe i haven't even gotten my housing
yet when everybody else that applied the
same time i did already has
i mean there's a lot of things i
question that's that big conspiracy
theory part like
i get a trespassing church from being
under the bridge i know people out there
is kind of stack of them
i had one
they took mine to trial
i asked my attorney
how many times you see that happen you
know go to that go to trial
never breathe i don't ever see that
happen
but mine did which is fine
because i was fortunate even though i've
lived a lifestyle that i've lived and
done the things that i've done selling
drugs and this that and the other i've
been very very
smart but very lucky also at the same
time and i don't have background
i have nothing on my criminal record
i don't go out and trick
and
i don't
usually do a lot of very criminal
activities except for over the past
seven years since when i first started
selling drugs hardcore
always peddled pot my whole life because
i think marijuana is one of the best
medicines
if there was just more dispensaries so
people get what they needed
but
i mean what is your main drug no
um
i i'm really good at selling ice i can
sell ice really well what do you use
um i
i think i've tried everything because i
mean i have very strong
um willpower and really you know have
good self-control and i've always wanted
to try everything i think if you know
what you can handle you should try
everything you only live once you know
what i'm saying and i have tried almost
everything
i don't know when i had to go to the
hospital a few months ago when they were
telling me what was my and my
my um drug
um whatever
you know
where they tested me to see what drugs i
had in my system they had said that
there was ecstasy in my system i said
yes if i could have just remembered that
because that was on my bucket list
i mean because i wanted to experience
those things i mean it is life though i
mean those things are a part of life i
mean it doesn't mean that you have to to
over indulge and become you know a
strong junkie just because you try
something one time but if you don't
think that you can handle it then don't
you know what i'm saying and if you know
yourself well enough and if you happen
to fall
into that and you try it and and you
lose yourself a long way through all
that
and you know it or somebody tells you go
get some help
i mean it's okay
you know what i'm saying we all lose
ourselves and we lose ourselves along
the way it happens it doesn't matter
what it is
you know
and now i mean just you know cocaine and
ecstasy and ice and heroin those aren't
you know all the only drugs out there in
the world tobacco and sex and food and
relationships and
sleeping i mean you name it those are
all addictions too or they can be
or coping mechanisms or whatever you
know i'm saying
so
you know um
have you had bad things happen to you on
the street
recently um i mean
which i don't understand that either
because i've been out here for 10 months
and i've held my own
and i always roll with the fellas you
know what i'm saying
and
freaking
i didn't see this coming
like i don't know how that one got past
me because you know a drug dealer too
you gotta read people really well
and i don't see how i missed this one i
think i was set up
and i i was raped about three weeks ago
to say roughly i may have lost
track of time there because you know
things have been kind of crazy here
lately
but
i don't know i miss that one
i've been able to walk like i've earned
my respect out here on the streets just
by
sitting down and listening to people you
know share their story with me because i
love people i love people one of my good
friends just died recently
and of course you noticed it was an
overdose but it wasn't an overdose he
nodded off and smothered together
against the tent from what i understand
you know which makes sense
but because he had drugs in his system
it was an overdose of course you know
because they're all we're all just
strung out junkies i guess at the end of
the day right so
however
that's what my mom says to punch my ass
she says you and all your junky friends
i said okay
watch yourself because my my junky
friends are some of the best people that
i have ever met in the world
they're amazing
and i said and if you knew my junky
friends ma
you wouldn't be so quick to calm my
chunky friends so you should probably
shut your mouth
because that's ignorant
oh that burned my head so bad when she
said that
but um
you know like heroin though
number one top
worst demon drug out there
i'm not gonna go with my health and go
through all the
the pick lines walking around the picc
lines anymore like i did the last time
and antibiotics at home the nurses and
the doctors and i mean i was at the
doctor twice a day like i ain't got it
in me and heroin i say people don't use
that one don't don't go with that one
but that one's got a hold of a lot of
people and i've lost a lot of people and
family
to that drug alone
and if i'm not real careful i can
probably lose myself to it because i do
use that sometimes to help take the edge
off my pain because
i hurt so bad and i'm not just talking
about this pain or this pain i'm talking
about my literally physical pain from
being sick you know my bones ached so
bad
i hurt so bad
i mean i didn't think i was gonna be
able to get up and walk and move today
i woke up in the middle of the night the
other night where i had done a little
bit age
and i know i was going through some
withdrawals and it scared [ __ ] out of me
because i'm not that person to be
there
and it
woke me up a little bit and told me oh
you better watch what you're doing
because
i don't want that demon on my back
because i don't want to fall prey to
that but also at the same time
right now with the way things are like i
could really find comfort in that
and i hate myself to be able to say that
but i don't have a problem owning my own
[ __ ]
and that's hard for all of us to do
people
said braces why people don't like you
because you just keep it real and you're
blunt and you just put it out there and
you don't mean to sound so bad about it
but it comes about across bad sometimes
but when you do that that's why people
don't like you because they have to own
their own [ __ ] and it's hard to own your
own [ __ ]
and sometimes we don't know what our own
[ __ ] is until somebody tells you too so
you know but i would rather somebody
tell me if i'm [ __ ] i don't see what
it is you know what i'm saying because i
i maybe could change that if i didn't
know
so until somebody tells you and you
don't see it
however
i'll tell you if i'm wrong it might take
me a minute too sometimes i will tell
you i'll own it every time however
eight
that's the one everybody
and and what i like to call my dope
amphetamines instead of methamphetamines
i mean that's a bad one too honest about
there's a demon there too because
instead of like with age words just
grabs ahold of you and it strikes you
slowly until you it takes you
or if you do it rather quickly and it
takes you really quick
that means i mean that will [ __ ]
drive you too though
because this is this one that it'll take
you so long that it's a process and and
and don't let that [ __ ] for you though
either though methamphetamines there are
people out there that use that drug that
you wouldn't have seen that coming i
know doctors
lawyers i mean i used to sell that
i know
i know everybody that's an everybody
drug and that's an everybody drug that
everybody can use because it doesn't
stay in your system that long
you know and maybe those people don't
have problems with it like that or maybe
they do i don't know
that's on them but you know that's an
everybody drugs so don't let people fool
you because the one that you would
the one that you think is not i
guarantee you pull their [ __ ] bedroom
door open beside their their bed and
he'll find their their damn rig or their
their dope pipe or whatever their piece
of oil
or or their parachute or their capsules
like i guarantee you they're doing it
too so you know don't let them for you
however
like i said the other ones
all this the pills the pills i never
dealt pills i don't like dealing pills
either
i mean because that takes you right to
the heroine really
i didn't like dealing drugs really at
all but i mean
tell me about getting robbed on the
street that must happen a lot getting
robbed on the street
well like just a way of life
well i mean on a hustler's stand point
of view
you can't get robbed if you don't allow
yourself to get robbed however
people steal from each other all the
time people have got to stop stealing
from each other whether you're homeless
or not people work too hard to have the
things that they have
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you in terms of robert
um
well um
the boy that one boy um
he wasn't robbing me but he was
threatening me
and he pulled it he pulled a pistol out
at nine
and he pointed it at me and he said bri
and i said yeah
he said well i should shoot you and i
said maybe you should i grabbed a hold
of the barrel that pissed the one i
pulled to my forehead maybe you might be
doing this off here at this point
he said uh
he said brian i think i might be a
little scared of you right now i said i
think maybe you might should be
i mean because
i mean we're all gonna die eventually
anyways
and i mean honestly like i seriously
have been threatening to take bullets in
the head
over the last 10 months by three
different people
that don't even know each other at three
different times the word for work i'm
gonna put a [ __ ] bullet in your head
well i mean if that's what's gonna
happen so be it
i mean i can walk out in front of a car
which i do all the time because i just
walk
because they're gonna stop
nobody's going to try to actually hit
you unless they're trying to hit you
and i know it's going to happen for me
anyways like they'll hit me and it won't
kill me
i'll be left to sit there to be picked
up by an ambulance and taken to the
hospital to suffer some more because
that's all i know is suffering
my whole life
and struggling and suffering and i
didn't mind the suffering and the
struggling because
there was amazing things but right now
all this isn't really so amazing anymore
like this moment right now this is
amazing and i'm grateful for this moment
because i've been trying to figure out
how to do this
and having this opportunity i i
thank you i'm grateful for this
sure
tell me brian brianna what's uh the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
my time is short way shorter than what
we realized
and
not to take things for granted
and to be humble
and to try to live
i mean like
try to find some happiness
and if you're lucky enough to be loving
in love and to love
love
and love
though i mean like
little joe looked at me and he said
he was mad at me and he was walking off
and i said well no matter what little
joey said i love you
he said well you don't even know me i
said i don't have to know you i said i
love your heart
i said i see past all that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] that facade
that you and everybody else and wait i
even i put project and put out there i
said i love you as a person we're all
human at the end of the day we all make
mistakes we all [ __ ] up and
you know but we all
put our pants on the same way nine times
out of ten or you know whatever and
you know we're all still here
not all of us so
because little joe's not here
all right brianna thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome thank
you for letting me i wish you the best
of luck out there thank you got you
drive
a little bit yeah but i'm good you got
me out of the weather yeah
thank you i appreciate it thank you
you